you
so hello everybody my name is Sam
Abraham's and I'm a los angeles-based
machine learning engineer one of the
things that I am known for known for I
don't like saying that but one of the
projects that I'm a part of is the
tensor flow of white paper notes
essentially it's just this annotated
guide to the white paper written for
tensor flow and released back in
November if you guys haven't read it and
are interested in how tensor flow is set
up what its infrastructure looks like I
highly recommend it it's a very
enjoyable easy to read but interesting
white paper I also am the maintainer for
the tensor flow for Raspberry Pi so if
you guys are interested in trying out
tensor flow on your Raspberry Pi trying
out some of the distributed functions of
tensor flow I have binaries up there for
both - - Python - and Python 3 so check
those out obviously completely free and
I am a contributor to the tensor flow
project it's obviously a lot of fun
getting the opportunity to work with
like even though it's digitally with a
lot of these really talented engineers
and if you guys want to improve
yourselves improve your engineering
ability I highly highly recommend
getting out there just finding something
right anything that you think could be
moderately improved just go out there
give it your best shot and they the
people in charge of the 10 circle
project will guide you and help you you
solve the problem they won't just do it
for you ok so I this talk is going to be
a sprint there's a lot of things I'm
trying to cover and I need I actually
want to ask you guys so it seems like
pretty much everyone here is for
tensorflow which is fantastic so just by
a show of hands Tim it or not how many
people have used tensor flow before ok
how many people have read about
tent-like sort of understand what tensor
flow is they have a good idea they've
done some research and they pretty much
know what
going on with tensorflow okay and then
how many people have heard about
tensorflow but really don't know very
much about it other than it's used for
machine learning it's cool it's it's
fast Google made it and I want to get a
part of it okay okay so we got like a
fairly diverse mix of people so we'll be
going through this and I'll do my best
to be thorough but at the same time I I
don't want to bore those who are using
tensorflow so we're gonna go over some
of the core tensorflow
API terminology I don't want anybody to
be left behind as we move forward
it's that on the whole tensorflow isn't
a very complex workflow but you don't
want to be I don't want people to get
lost when we start talking about graphs
and edges and adding notes and all that
like I said well talk about the
tensorflow workflow I want to show you
guys some example tensorflow code and
we're gonna try to do a little bit of a
lot of mini live coding session I you
know you don't want to have those go too
long but I do want to showcase some
really cool features of tensorflow
will go for tensor board tensor board
being one of the really really cool
visualization software that comes with
tensor flow it's just like part of the
package it's great okay so let's talk
about the tensor flow of programming
model any of you guys have used the you
know before it's very very similar it's
another it's another graph based engine
computation graph based engine the user
facing API so most jet pretty much
everybody using tensor flow on a day to
day basis is going to be interfacing it
with Python but it is the majority of
the actual execution code is written in
C++ so that the idea is that we have
this very user-friendly nice Python
interface in the front but the actual
meat going on underneath is this already
compiled C++ code which allows it to be
much more efficient than
the something like Python so the
computational code that said was written
in is written in C++ and that there are
separate implementations for either CPU
or GPU for each of the functions written
in tensorflow
so if something in general everything is
capable of being run on CPU and if they
can get additional benefit of being run
on a GPU or if they're if it just is
possible to run it on a GPU even if it
isn't highly parallelized tensorflow is
able to decide to put operations either
on the CPU or GPU based on what is
possible to go where if any of this is a
data science hub it would seem so I'm I
assume that a lot of you guys are
familiar at least with numpy it's one of
the lingua Franca's of data science it's
it's the ultimate Python and dimensional
array library tensorflow is designed to
be completely and utterly integrated
with numpy you can pass in numpy objects
as as if they were tensorflow objects
and objects returned at the end of
tensorflow runs are actually numpy
objects which means you can seamlessly
go from manipulate manipulating your
data passing it into a tensor flow graph
and then getting receiving some data
transform data and then playing around
with it some more with numpy okay so
tensor for programming pretty much at
the end of the day boils down to two
steps the first step is to build the
graph that you want to run so you build
a node you have all these different
steps right and you haven't run it yet
then you use a tensor flow session to
run it as many times as you want so the
in for machine learning right the idea
here is that you build a graph you build
your model that is what you that
be your prediction step right and then
you have a you we analyze the error then
we do some sort of gradient descent back
if for a neural network you back
propagate right and then that you run it
multiple multiple times with each to run
corresponding to a single training batch
right makes sense pretty good okay cool
all right so let's talk about graphs so
they're the at the core of everything is
the graph right it's the primary
structure of tensor flow and in general
when you're making your own models
you're only going to have a single graph
that you're dealing with but you should
know that tensor flow is capable of
handling multiple graphs and that may or
may not come up later I'm not I don't
remember exactly what's going on but
with this guy but you should know that
it's possible to run multiple graphs and
there's no reason not to in fact you can
think of one big graph right you can you
can think of it as being able to be
split in half and being two separate
graphs if you'd like right nodes
represent computations or data
transformations so I don't know how many
of you guys are familiar with your bit
with basic graphs and graph theory it's
pretty much just circles and lines but
nodes represents computations or data
transformations and edges represent data
transfers so you'll have circles that
represent computations like add or
multiply our matrix multiply and then
they convey edges between them the lines
connecting those our arrows saying okay
this the output from this addition is
going to move on to the next node which
might be multiplication okay so we're
gonna basically go through this
hopefully this isn't too dull but I
don't want to leave anybody behind if
nobody seen graphs in mathematical form
before so what is a data flow graph it's
also known as a computational graph
right it's just a very nice way to
visualize an abstract mathematical
computations so this is a very simple
graph showcasing the
right so we have some input a we have
some input B right they move their data
so here we have the number B moving up
to this node we have the number a moving
to this node we end up with a plus B and
then this plus Multan will output some
the value of a plus B pretty simple
right and the idea is that we can chain
these together we already went through
these nodes and edges before right so we
have nodes representing operations we
have edges representing numbers so why
use graphs one they're super highly
compositional that means that they are
incredibly flexible for research for
research purposes so the pheno torch a
lot of these other machine learning
libraries are useful because it allows
researchers to kind of put together
these very fluid and flexible
models without having to worry about
whether or not their library can support
it right it if you're using this very
heavy-handed layer by layer approach you
may not be able to get the sort of
flexibility that you're looking for and
may not be able to tweak your model to
the degree necessary to get that extra
percentage of correct estimation in
addition graphs are useful for
calculating derivatives if any of you
guys remember your chain rule yeah
anyone anyone up for calculus know if
you guys are getting into machine
learning I highly recommend you falling
in love with calculus again not the hard
parts of calculus just like the easy
derivative but bits that's not true you
should learn all of it but basically
what you can do with the chain rule if
you if you recall your chain rule I
didn't want to like pull out the
whiteboard but basically you can you the
idea is that we have a function f of X
right and we have a function G of X or G
of Y right and then we want we have the
the problem of G of f of X
right and so the goal is to get the
derivative of G with respect to X but we
have this Y in the middle we need to
figure out how to get like how do we get
there and the answer is you take the
derivative of G with respect to Y and
multiply that with by of F with respect
to X and math math happens and you have
what you want right
so the key the key with that is that you
can the whole reason they called the
chain rules that you can it doesn't just
go two layers deep right it goes very
deep deep that's why they call it deep
learning right so but you can basically
start with you can have this layer a
network that is many many layers deep
has goes very far back and you can get
the correct derivative with respect to
any of your inputs right and if any of
you guys have gone through like your
basic neural network training you know
that back propagation is all about
calculating the chain rule backwards
throughout a graph cool that's another
reason why we use graphs it's also
easier to implement implement
distributed computing this is pretty
straightforward basically if you can
segment your computation into individual
chunks it's way easier to place them on
different graphs and on different
threads it's already segmented nice it
you can see and like I said neural
networks are pretty much already
computation graphs okay
I'll try to sprint through this bastard
tensor is just in case you guys are
uncomfortable with that terminology all
they are is an abstraction of a matrix
right so if a two dimensional tensor is
a matrix a one-dimensional tensor is a
vector a zero dimensional tensor is just
a scalar or just a single number and
then as you go higher you can have a
three that you can imagine a
three-dimensional matrix as a cube if
you want Anna for dementia matrix as a
hypercube or whatever in reality there
you just think of them as any sort of
higher dimensional or RAZR matrices
right if you in general in tensor flow
most of the math actually happens in two
dimensions anyway that's not the case
for every operation but in general if it
is easier for you to just think of them
as
matrices feel free to do so I won't
judge you and that's what's important
okay so just to go for how you would
define tensors in up tensorflow for
those who haven't seen it you can either
do them as standard Python lists so you
can see up here on the top we have a
scaler it's just a single number you can
pass this in to type tensorflow
operations and it'll just read it as a
tensor right same thing with a single
vector right or we can have a list of
lists and have a matrix or we can have a
list of lists of lists and have a
three-dimensional tensor and you can go
even further or it's like I said you can
that tensorflow integrates seamlessly
with numpy and you can basically do the
same thing use the same sort of verbage
I guess right but it's wrap it in an NP
or a wrapper and the reason you would
want to do this and this is actually
pretty important you won't you probably
won't see this very much
in the slides but I encourage you as
you're learning tensorflow to use numpy
for this is you can specify the exact
type of data type that you'd like Python
is a very loosely loosely typed language
weakly typed even and the the thing is
tensorflow has a very robust selection
of types available to it which go all
the way down to the c++ implementation
but because python doesn't have a way of
specifying whether or not you want a
32-bit floating-point in or a 64-bit
floating-point number or 64-bit integer
etc you aren't able to do to specify
that information without using numpy so
if you use numpy you can do exactly that
and you won't have to deal with weird
like type mismatch errors as you move
along okay so that's my that's that's a
piece of advice number one so like I
said please use no virus
not doing it because I'm lazy this time
and it's base is limited okay like I
said I've been using the phrase
operations you'll also see the word op
we I've been intentionally trying to
stop not say up because of DevOps and
that whole field that maybe can they
just just don't bother with that I'll
see operations with a capital L they
represent any sort of computations and
in tensor flow and operation is as
you'll see it as a Python function you
call it you pass in your inputs 0 or
more tensors as an input and it will do
any sort of computation so these
computations can be as simple as adding
two tensors together they can do
something that has nothing to do with
math itself but may initialize variables
they may do other operations that affect
the graph in one way or another right
but the main idea is that you pass in
zero or more tensors they return zero
more tensors and the big thing that may
catch some people off is that they don't
immediately execute right the idea is
that you were you are what you get after
you run that Python function is a handle
to that operation right you'll get a
handle to the output of that operation
you can pass that output to another
operation or you can run that output and
have the graph run to that point so just
remember when you are dealing with
operations they won't run
instantaneously so when you say ok a
equals one and B equals two and C equals
TF dot add a plus B a and B right you
won't get the number three you'll get a
handle you'll get a tensorflow operation
which will if you run write which we'll
go over later will return three okay
hopefully I'm not making it more say
that say that again
exactly so that's exactly the idea is
that you have access to the the
operation itself like the concept of the
operation and it knows that it's taking
in those inputs but it hasn't actually
it's lately evaluating that lazily right
so here's just a quick example right so
we're using the simple multiplication
this isn't matrix multiplication it's
just simple basic multiplication first
we import tensorflow well by convention
we shorten that to TF because writing
tensor flow every time is sadistic we
are going to just create we're gonna say
a equals TF that mole and you'll notice
we're just passing these indirectly like
as I said I'm not using numpy because
I'm a bad person and we're
getting--we're what a is is a handle to
this multiplication node right well when
we get it it doesn't it doesn't return
the number 15 yet what we have to do is
start a session and we'll talk more
about sessions soon and then once we
have opened up a session we can run it
and then finally it returns 15 hooray
okay so let's talk a little bit about
placeholders so placeholders are your
input notes so you can imagine as you're
running graphs that you're not always
going to want to use static like you're
not gonna want to use the same numbers
every time you run the graph when you're
doing machine learning you're gonna need
to be passing it training data and
you're gonna need to be plate giving it
the labels for that data as well right
so the idea is that you give a four
tensorflow
in order for to be able to compute
matrix multiplications it needs to know
the dimensions of the matrices right so
when you specify a place where you say
well tentatively I don't have any data
for you yet but I do know it's gonna be
a hundred by 400 so you can calculate
all the other shapes you need to do in
order to make sure everything matches
nicely so when you create a placeholder
that's exact
when you do you give it the data type
and you give it the shape you can also
get this is a side note you can give all
these notes names which I'll be doing in
the live coding demo as it's good
practice but just for the essential
things you have to do you you have a you
just need to give it the data type in
the shape and then you can use my
placeholder as you would any other
tensor you can pass that into a in
addition operation or a multiplication
operation or matrix multiplication
operation okay now let's talk about
actually running a session okay so the
session is in charge of coordinating
your graph so tensorflow by default you
know has one graph and it's just kind of
hanging out in the background and as you
are coding and adding in more and more
nodes it's keeping track of what's going
where who's outputting to what what
dependencies are involved right and the
session is the master of that and the
most important method as we saw before
is the run method
it's what actually will run the graph
and you get you what you want so it
takes in two parameters there is fetches
and there's feeds dect so fetches is a
list of objects and those objects are
tensors nodes in your graph that you'd
like to get the results for and your
common example is the final layer in a
neural network but you can actually pass
it in any tensor that's in your graph so
the idea is if there's something there's
if there's an operation that you would
like to run then you just pass it in to
the tensor flow session and the reason
that this is nice is that you can if
you'd like you don't have to run your
entire graph if that's not where you're
interested in and because of the the
nature of your graphs it's only going to
run the the nodes previous right the the
dependencies of that node and it won't
run the entire graph for no reason we
say that again so by default it's going
if you just run session run it's gonna
just print it to the console you can
save it as an output right so
these operations will output zero or
more tensors right so for for example
for you ran the this the back going back
to the ad right or the multiplication by
default it's just going to print out the
number 15 if you you can save that to a
variable if you'd like and you can Oh
are you asked a Kashuk - sorry caching
drew by Z run yeah so from what I
understand it will do its best that
though the the the issue is that for
many of the most commonly used graphs
it's you won't like when you're doing
training right it's the the caching of
data is useful isn't very useful because
you end up having a dependency on a
placeholder or your input which changes
each time you run right but denser fluid
does its best to not like waste people's
time and memory right coming back okay
then
this bead dick parameter so we talked
about how we have placeholders there's
actually a number of ways to give values
to those placeholders to those input
values what we the sort of most common
way you would see it done these days is
when you're not do especially when
you're not doing a distributed session
let's use this feed dict parameter
basically if you what all the feed dick
is is you give it the permit you give it
a dictionary that's what the dicta part
is where the key that you passed into it
is the handle to the node that you want
to give the input value to right you
give it the handle to your placeholder
node and then the value that you in the
dictionary is the tensor value that you
want to give it right so in the previous
one I don't know if I have an example I
can show it in later yeah
I can type this in later but for the
previous example for this placeholder we
would give it a feed dictionary where
the key is my placeholder just the not
know quotes around it just my
placeholder and then the value would be
this hundred by four hundred ten sir
that we want to run cool okay here we go
here we go
tensorflow variables these are variables
that persist over time that you want to
that will basically be able to take on
different values and slowly change over
time or drastically change over time
maybe like weights and your neural
network that you want to train or any
parameters in your machine Learning
Network
like I said weights and biases and the
like you said as you if you know machine
learning the final values that you have
after your training these will be the
parameter the main parameters that
you've been trying to get before you run
in the graph you have to initialize them
and that's just part of the housekeeping
of tensorflow session the basic idea is
the tensor flow has to know when you
want like we give the variable a
starting value but it doesn't know
exactly when you want to give it that
because it's possible that you've
trained for a while and then you want to
the it's possible that you start at zero
and then you train them you're like I
messed up I want to start again so
there's a there's a node or there's an
operation called initialized variable
that you can use to initialize a single
variable and then you can use a helper
method for that but it says I've
initialized all my variables that will
set your variables to the starting value
that you give them sorry for spewing
that at you so there used to be the like
it's still in most of the documentation
you'll see this tensorflow variable like
direct call as the way to initialize
your variables this is okay but for a
multiple tutor of reasons namely having
to do with having trying to give your
variables or passive variables around
two different scopes variable scopes
it's best practice to use TF get
variable the this is this is hard to
cover without having to being able to
describe what variable scopes are but
the basic idea is you can have variables
with similar names that are in you can
have a graph right so imagine this big
big old graph and we have we define a
variable over in this section right and
this section for the most part doesn't
see this section of the graph over here
the main the big thing though is that
they have one variable that they both
want to be able to manipulate and it
just becomes a lot simpler if you use TF
get variable because you give it a
specific name and you're able to call it
them there so that's the basic idea of
why you want to use get get variable
that said I'm probably going to just end
up using tensor float variable anyway
because these graphs are making are
pretty straightforward when you have
when you want to update a sign-up date
its value directly you can use the
assign method okay so finally we're sort
of closing the loop of this the this
intro section so this couple of what
we're trying to do here is create this
this note here over this graph with
tensorflow code so you create that once
you create this placeholder variable
you're gonna end up with X all right so
we're calling we're calling our
placeholder X so BAM we're gonna get
this graph here then we're gonna have a
tensorflow variable that's gonna have
the starting value of zero and so then
that just gets placed onto the graph
nothing's executed yet right and then
we're gonna create a new node called Y
and we're gonna have that B be assign
method rather I should say we're going
to assign the value of we have a node
called like we have a node that's going
to be the assign operation
and it is going to take in the values of
start which is itself right and then
also it's going to take an X here sorry
so the basic idea is that each one of
these each one of these lines of code
represents an operation and then the
ways that we pass in the values to each
other to find the edges yes sir say that
again
yeah so how does how does it know that
they should move together here okay so
the basic idea is so we start with node
X right and when we first define the
code we would have just X by itself with
no arrows pointing anywhere it's just a
node hanging out in space it we have we
have like as the programmer have access
to its output right but for now all the
program cares abouts like okay X is
hanging out that's all we care about and
then the same thing with start in
isolation rax X is still here with no
arrows but for all intents and purposes
start is hanging out by itself but once
we call this assign method once we call
this assign operation all of a sudden we
we start with saying okay we're going to
place this assign operation we're going
to call it Y but we're just gonna have
this assign operation place on the node
so let's what inputs do we need like
what values do we need in order to make
this run and we see oh we have a handle
for the start this value start and then
it was okay so that means we need to
place this but this operation here week
because we're taking it in as an input
technically this is gonna get turned
into an add operation and then the add
operation is gonna get placed up here
but for simplicity sake we're just gonna
stick with this
so we're saying okay we're taking in the
start value as an input right and that
goes up here
exactly so it basically the way it works
is it knows that it needs to place an
operation down on the graph and then it
looks at its inputs and says oh these
are the these are the things that I'm
dependent on that means I'm going to
have an edge here right and so this node
actually if you look at it will keep
track of its own dependencies and that's
how it knows Oh in order for me in order
for me to run I know that I need both of
these guys to have run I need to know
what their outputs are right cool any
more questions on that yes sir
okay so the this start this start
variable is actually a variable variable
so this is a tensor flow variable object
right so it's not a Python variable it
is a variable object which has its own
sets of methods and one of those methods
is the assign method which is its own
even though it's an internal method it's
still in operation that makes sense
right
yeah so if that's that's what it as a
sign is a method of exactly correct well
I could mean XII missed the the details
of those so so the X is a placeholder
right so start at is a is a variable
object right you can use it as a tensor
it will be converted into a proper
tensor object I'm not sure if I don't
think it inherits from tensor but the
variable has its own set of methods a
place holder would have its own and it
doesn't have a sign as its own right
cool yes
yes so a sign then a sign doesn't
increment it or do something else it
gives you give it the exact value that
you want right so if you wanted to
increment it by 1 you would say start
plus 1 if that makes sense right it's so
big right what this operation does is it
increment this increments start right so
start we want to give a new value to
start we want that new value to be start
plus some value cool yeah yes I mean
this was a to be honest I wrote this
this slide Oh like I may possibly a
month or two ago and I haven't looked at
it and it needed the updated so yes it
is very poorly constructed it's still
technically correct but yes I apologize
for the confusion of the of that right
my goal was to you to look like showcase
the variable functionality and it just
happened to be done and maybe not the
most helpful way right so the question
is is it possible to have essentially a
cyclic graph is it possible for it at
some point where we have all these you
know again we have more nodes and then
eventually we have a value over here
that says like Oh what if start equals
that right and then we end up having
this endless feedback loop so it's a
very good question and the answer in
short is no you can't really use it
because of the weight dependencies work
right in theory you end up with a
paradox like chicken what came first the
chicken or the egg what came first the
start or the operation that came before
start which is also after start
so you'll see you'll see graphs or every
recurrent neural networks that look like
we need to have a cyclic graph right
you'll see I wish I had a way to draw
this out and not scribble on this but
essentially a common can I draw on this
wall it looks like it's draw okay so
you'll see you'll see recurrent neural
network basic things right that
essentially look like something like
this right where they have this they
like feed that looks like they feed back
into themselves right
and the thing is this model that this
infinite model of recurrent neural
networks is really more theoretical than
something that we can actually do right
we could we can't go infinitely into the
past's and we can't go infinitely into
the future so what we end up doing is
what's called unrolling the the model
right so when you see something like
this right what's actually happening
isn't this thing that's feeding back
into itself infinitely what you're
actually seeing is something that's
closer to so now like we're gonna rotate
this because there's not a lot of
horizontal so now we're gonna say
instead of it would be like feeding like
this so we're gonna say like we're we're
checking we're checking out this value
here and then we have the same model up
here and we have an output there and we
have this and it just keeps going up as
many times as we'd like and it may seem
difficult to see like how this matches
the recurrent model but the idea is okay
we started at this point in time here we
feed it into our model it does some
processing and we're gonna observe it
out we're gonna observe its output at
that time and then we're going to feed
it back into the same model right and
the key that makes this work is that the
weights right all the all the big weight
matrices in here are identical and they
are updated at the same time okay and as
soon as you do that you end up with a
model that in effect emulates in a true
recursion right
true cyclic graph without having the the
headaches of a cyclic graph dependency
so the in the in if you wanted to try to
do that in tensor flow the reality is as
soon what happens is if you tried to
reassign start to a value that so if you
try to reassign the value of start to it
like a new a new operation right so
let's say we now take this right
afterwards we say start equals y plus 2
or whatever it is in tensor flow speak
write like oh did we do it did we break
tensor flow well under the hood what's
actually happening is there is the graph
is getting defined node by node and
what's actually happening is this
original start that we use is staying
right there right what's happened what
would happen is that we create a new
node right somewhere maybe up here right
this is okay it's y equals x plus start
plus two right so we're sitting like y
plus two and we're gonna call it start
so just because it has the same variable
name doesn't mean that it's gonna get
it's gonna bump the old start off the
graph what we will lose is the handle
because we're changing this Python
variable right we're changing what
that's pointing to and instead of this
the word start pointing to this it's
going to point to the new operation in
the graph does that answer your question
do you feel good where do you want okay
yes exactly I mean not you'll have to
ask this guy but I'm not sure whether
like are all tensor is immutable always
okay cool I thought so but I didn't want
to say that because I'm like yeah
yeah cool but it's very very good
question it's that's like something
that's fun to explore so yeah that's
that's building a graph and also
recurrent neural networks and also
enrolling them okay so we we are they
mean we've already gone through this I
don't want to to basically run this into
the dirt the basic idea is you start a
session you have to initialize the
variables right so that's what I was
talking about before this initialize all
variables is an OP and I forgot to put
in parentheses here you have to run that
operation and then you're allowed to use
the variable okay and then this is a
terminology thing
the term devices so a device is a CPU or
GPU it does not mean a computer or a
whole machine a machine can have
multiple devices I don't know if you
guys saw this in the news but Google
announced that they've made their own
tensor processing units for their cloud
computing it's gonna be so cool except
they're so expensive and maybe not
practical but you know kind of fun so
yeah just know that multi device doesn't
necessarily mean distributed if you have
a regular computer with a GPU on it you
can run a multi device setup because you
can run it on have part of it executed
on the GPU and part of it executing on
the CPU but it all stays within the same
machine okay
so we're gonna try to turn this into
like I feel like this I'm I feel like
I'm going on for a long time but I don't
I don't know what the time limits we
have here but I want to do talk about
tensor board quickly because it's very
cool and if you've worked with tensor
flow and haven't used it it's very easy
to make just a lot of great use out of
it basically tensor board allows you to
visualize your models it allows you to
visualize statistics from your graph
from your models and it can help you
make sure that you are doing it like
basically it can help you make sure that
you are that your models match what
you've sketched out on paper right so
let's I'd want to do a brief life devil
demo I don't I don't need to get into
the like crazy details about these
scalars like doing a bunch of summaries
but I wanted to show you guys how easy
it is to just visualize your graph
instantly okay so we're gonna close out
of this we're gonna open up terminal
let's start this guy up okay so we're
gonna create a new tensor flow Python
notebook we're gonna import tensor flow
yeah that we're system I do this we're
gonna import tensor air we're gonna have
a boy tensor flow as TF okay so we run
this it's gonna go perfect okay so now
let's create our basic graph okay so
we're gonna say a equals some basic
tensor and like I said I'm bad person
I'm not using dumb pi so we have this
and then we're gonna have B equals let's
do one two we're going to make this an
actual matrix 1 2 3 4 5 6 comma 7 8 9
cool so now we have these two tensors
that we're going to be able to use and
now we're going to want to do a matrix
multiply
so we'll say C equals T f dot Matt well
let's see if I get these right on the
first time I'm going to say B and a you
can't remember that it's gonna be right
damn backwards
know what I do transpose B what's that
right I think they are this guy needs to
be yeah you're right I think if we do
that maybe
there we go thank you
okay sorry this so this vectors in make
vectors bad matrices good okay so now we
have these nodes on our graph and now we
can open up the session and now like
just as a demo we can say to session dot
run C and we should get the correct
array right hooray but that's not what
we're here for
what we're here for is to open up a
writer is it summary writer or yeah
mmm-hmm no dude these it's actually
pretty fast I feel like it's this isn't
opening itself up right wanted to
double-check this summary writer we have
to pass it in the is it yeah we have to
pass it in a log directory so the first
value is just the my graph right so it's
gonna output some data here and then we
also need to pass it in the actual the
the graph of this session so a session
that graph we do this right no it's not
so what does that do around here for AC
I feel like summary writers not right
I mean I just don't see the summary
writer thing mink
deep apologies we're gonna go to the
tensorflow API real quick to do just as
a side note the defensive love API your
resources are actually not trained that
thank you sir no the part of the magic
is that you don't need to do oh like
we're not we're not going to be going
over the crazy like the summary
statistics that are available because
that's a little bit more involved it's
the same thing my my graph and then
we're passing in the graph but we'd like
it to that we'd like it to write great
okay so now it doesn't look like much
has happened but if we go into this
notebook we close this out and then we
look it's gonna be huge but we're gonna
go into we're going to start a tensor
board we look up somewhere we should see
yes somewhere in there okay
let's the tensor board and then we'll
say vlogged or equals my crap okay great
so now we see that there's something
happening we have some something good on
port 606 so if we go to localhost at 600
six well we're gonna get brought to
tensor board you'll see there's no
scalar data this is I meant where we're
not showing any summary statistics but
if we go to graph look at that
so we have our inputs here yeah look
cool I know I knew I did and it's gonna
make you guys happy at some point yeah
so for all my rambling I sort of know
what I'm doing so basically you can see
that we just wrote in three different
and I apologize for all this it's just
the low resolution on the one presenting
but what what tensor flow is is this
highly interactive very very cool way of
visualizing your nodes very quickly
right and so you can see that you have
data coming in you can click on any of
your attributes and take a look-see at
some of its information and as the
scales up you can create names
namespaces which allow you to basically
minimize your graph into the bigger and
smaller spaces in fact I can it's not
not really worth it but basically all
you need to do like to get yourself
started with tensor board add your add
just add in a TF dot train that summary
writer passing your graph and you're
gonna be able to immediately start
visualizing your graph and seeing it and
you won't have to worry about anything
else you don't have to do it you don't
have to do anything else
it's just like oh great I can sanity
check to make sure that I'm not doing
anything really dumb so unfortunately
tensor board is not a lie like a live
stream what it does is it saves data to
that my graph file or whatever you
wanted to call it but what you what you
can what you should be using it for is
it's basically saying oh that doesn't
look like I would I expected it to
that like this isn't connected to
dollars this is like I'm completely
missing something or I forgot to do this
right so it's really useful as a sanity
check er and it's also once you start
getting used to it you can use it to
actually test your keep track of your
training data over time and visualize
that there's histograms and the scatter
plots and all sorts of their feature
that I'm not able to show to you in such
a short
live coding session but there are things
there yes sir oh sorry so yeah basically
when you install tensorflow it comes
with when you install it it comes with
this tensor board command so all your
typing is tensor board and then we're
passing in a log der flag to pass in the
directory that we want to use okay so if
you recall in the code in here I called
it I basically said to save it to my
graph and that's why we were able to
pass it in here cool
yeah there's there's third party yeah
it's it's it's very cool and tensor
board is one of those things that
everybody knows is really cool but I
don't think people appreciate how simple
it is to actually start making use of it
yes sir
why is it so small can I do this
there you go
so let people write down this simple the
this this code really quickly any other
questions about tensor board I know that
there's a lot of features that I didn't
cover but any anything else that we went
over quickly here very very cool
all right sir yes okay so that so that
that's okay right so you'll see that
scalar data is so just to describe what
you would be doing right so I this
writer is actually a live object right
the it's something that you can open up
and close as you would any other file
writer right so what the writer does is
you open it up and when you pass in the
session graph it says oh okay I like
because the graph the graph definition
doesn't depend on the the data flowing
through it necessarily right it's when
we're just talking about the can there
are connections there are these types of
like these types of operations are
happening and they depend on these other
nodes right it's as soon as you open up
the writer can say oh yeah I can I can
write down that and that's what we're
that's what we get there but there's a
whole lot more we can do with this
writer and that includes a number of
summer of summary operations so if you
go to the tensorflow API and just look
up summary right and just search for
those you'll see histogram summaries
you'll see scaler summaries and all of
those are you pass those in to the
writer and basically say writer dot you
know add summary and put that put the
scalar summary in there
you just say okay I want to keep track
of this weight over time like every
hundred iterations right you'll see in
sample code it'll do a modulo of your
step your training steps and say okay
every 200 steps I want to save the value
of this weight and I also want to save
the percentage correct or incorrect that
we got I also want to get the standard
deviation of these valve variables and
whatever right
so you can the thing with this is
incredibly flexible it is hands-on you
do have to explicitly tell it what you
want but it gives you the power to be
able to say what you want to save
exactly when and so when you first load
up tensor border they'll say no scalar
data's bound you're like oh god I
up but you didn't
don't worry right so I mean right so
over you know you the people who have no
data science here know that a lot of
what we're looking at is how how much
better is our model doing over time over
training data iterations and how and how
does it compare to other models in
general and what statistics can we use
to basically get a good sense of whether
or not it's doing well you can have your
training error and then you have your
validation error right and then your
test error but then you can also just
look at things like you can create you
know if you would like if you wanted to
you can construct like create a model
that is worth constructing p-values for
and whatever right so the the key here
right is I I've just touched like the
very very tip of tensor board and
introduced it as a way for you to
visualize your code right as the graph
because at the end of the day tensorflow
is all about building a computation
graph and the more and more you can get
used to just thinking of your code as
well I got circles and I got arrows
connecting those circles and this is how
gonna do it in code the more comfortable
you are with that concept the more
fluent you're going to become with
tensor flow and tensor board is a great
way to immediately give you feedback on
how your mental image compares to what
tensor flow is showing you and but again
tensor board also allows you to do much
more sophisticated data analysis right
as well as just give you like doing
something as simple as keeping track of
your test error over time and giving you
that very you know the nice downward
sloping error rate over time so you
wouldn't need to do that so the metaphor
the thing with some with tensor board is
you you run your graph and it's tensor
board saves your your statistics right
so we can close this we can come back
tomorrow right and it's just saved in
this my graphic folder right the it's as
much as it's sad that tensorflow our
tensor board doesn't work in real time
and show you data flowing through your
graph and just like oh my god I can see
little dots flowing that'd be really
cool but at the same time it's also kind
of nice it's it's stable and you come
back to it and you'll have the same
statistics you can use it as a data
dashboard if you're trying to show it to
clients or if you're working with
colleagues and you need to show them
that you can basically use tensor board
as that data dashboard yes sir
yeah so I mean that this comes down to
the type of model you're training so and
this is this is something that expands
beyond just tensorflow this is just
model comparison in general so one
example of ways you could do it right so
obviously you have your your how like
does it learn right does your model like
machine learning model learn and at the
end of your training sessions which
model learned this has a lower test or
higher test score that's one way but
then you can change it'll be like well
there's more to it than that how how
quickly right how quickly does this
those this model train and you can graph
you the learning rate over time right
you can do things that are akin to
seeing whether you can basically
visualize what if we didn't train on the
data enough right you look at that you
look at your training graph and it's
it's still sloping down at a pretty good
clip and then we just stopped let's say
we only did 3,000 training iterations
and what if we had done 10,000 right we
might be able to have a better idea of
oh it looked like this model was still
learning maybe we needed to just run it
for longer right so it's the the
question of how do you know which model
is better is it or how do you compare
them that's basically tensorflow
our tensor board allows you to keep
track of statistics that you would like
right sophistic that you would think are
important for comparing models training
training or training rate the size of
you know the size of the model the
number of you can keep track with the
number you could calculate the number of
parameters going on or whatever though
that would stay the same over time
well I mean I mean the at the end of the
day for that it's not the tensor tensor
board isn't gonna like be like check
mark this one's super better like
because we just know and you know with
with all of these machine learning tools
right it's it's not just it's not just a
magic black box it's is gonna be able to
to do the critical thinking for you
right at the end of the day it's it's
what its gonna try to do is be able to
present data to you in a way that is
useful and digestible
I mean basically basically I use sensors
I use tensor board to keep track of my
my learning my learning rates might it's
like I said before your test test
validation training error it's like
there's there are you know I'm projects
I'm working on right now I am working on
a parking meter for a predictive parking
parking meter application right and so
we're able to take a look at the we can
take a look at the percentage of parking
meters available at a given time and we
can we can filter that by location right
we can decide which parking which areas
we want to track for a given cycle and
have that feed into tensor board we can
have tensor board do all like we can do
it by block and have tensor board keep
track of all of the blocks at the same
time and have it just be this giant grid
that's not particularly like that's a
little overwhelming but you can do it
like that
but at the end the day it's tense it's
just a nice way to be able to graph
information from your from your back
well I mean this again yeah yeah so I
would say that if you're in terms of
like comparing your model right you
can't look at the looking at the graph
of the model isn't going to be give you
a better way of saying oh this model is
better because it look it look it look
just look at it just look at how much
better it is yeah no that's better for
debugging your code right so the the use
of being able to look at your graph is
being able to keep track of making sure
that when you're doing these models it's
very I find it very useful to actually
draw out what and what my inputs are
what the maître matrix sizes are what's
being connected to what other if I'm
inputting some auto and auto encoder off
to the side right draw that in and make
sure that I have all my inputs
transformed correctly so I would say
that the yes sir
I would say that the graphing thing that
I just showed you is good for debugging
and visualizing your code and the
summary statistics are good for
analyzing the success or the actual
training of your of your model cool yes
sir
so the so what will happen is you'll
you'll run your session right and what
you'll what you'll end up doing is
having a a you'll have a writer
operation write a summary up you'll
write out all the different summaries
that you'd like and then in general the
useful thing that people do is create
use an operation called
I think it's collect all summaries or
merge all merge all summaries and so
merge all summaries all it does is says
okay I'm gonna find all of the summaries
I'm going to bunch them all together so
that we can easily run those and then
let's see if I can do this all right so
so I believe unfortunately like
unfortunately this is something that I
would hope will be updated soon but when
you tensor board will pretty much read
the data once as this or when the server
is running and so in order to update
with new data you'll just have to
control C and then up hit tensor board
again I may be wrong with that
but in my experience it's the server
doesn't try to reread data as it changes
so that that is yeah yeah I don't want
to I don't want to hold like this guys
got cool stuff I hope so
as anything anymore like last minute I
know like there's a tensor board is I
didn't really get deep enough into it to
be able to satisfy satisfy your desires
but or you feel you feel good
yeah cool cool so we'll showcase some
more intricate examples of that and so I
just I'll really try to do this as fast
as I can
but I just want to go over if you want
to get deeper into the tensor flow right
it's because pretty much everything I
talked about was fairly high level and
for like people who just had a curse
like either just heard about it or they
have haven't really practiced with it
okay so let's talk about yeah yeah right
okay and unfortunately I don't have a
huge amount of time to talk about this
yeah yeah hopefully you guys are
learning something not feeling like this
is a too slow for you all but let's talk
about the code base because pencil goes
a very cool framework so as Chris talked
about we it starts at the bottom and
then the stacks up from there so at the
at the very root of tensorflow is your
standard C++ library is including
heavily heavy heavy use of the eigen
library which if you haven't seen before
check it out it's very cool high highly
optimized implementations of matrix out
math right then on top of that we have
the tensorflow core framework that's
where you have your graphs you have your
matrices in C++ you have your operations
in C++ and then on top of that right so
you have the the enterprise level like
structure then you actually have the
implementation of that and that's in
your the tensorflow slash course less
kernel right you actually see the
detailed code and you'll have your C
plus your CPU implementations you'll
have your GPU implementations great
those get compiled and then we need to
figure out a way to connect those to
Python so we use swig swig is a native
way of connecting like C++ compiled code
and hooking that up into higher-level
languages in this case we're using
Python and then you have all the Python
library on top
that okay so from what I understand
again has a lot more focus on scientific
Matt like mathematical implementations
so you have very efficient
implementations of like the hyperbolic
tangent function right things that are
useful in data science that you may not
see in from the simple more rudimentary
though very very useful arithmetic
operations that you'd see in other
libraries it's it's a tux family of
sweets so I'm not exactly sure the so
Google ish but yeah it's I mean it's
something that I did more research on
that door I saw tensor flow it's you
know it's got pretty good documentation
though the website does look like it's
from 1997 but you know it's I highly
recommend checking out again because if
you want if you're interested in getting
into implementing your own code and
tensor flow if you know C++ or
interested in learning more about this
sort of implementation learning eigen or
at least getting a good sense of the
basic I cannae PAP is will give you a
much more comfortable time looking at
the tensor flow court code as it calls a
lot of eigen code so I wanted for the
rest of this talk of gonna try to go
over the just the structure of the
tensor flow repository because it's not
explicitly made clear what what's what
and where you'll find things right and
then I just want to quickly go over some
basic concepts if you do if you are
already doing it or thinking about
getting into implementing your own
operations we're going to be doing more
of that at the
at the workshop next Saturday but it's
just too much to try to cover as you you
guys see how long it takes me to get
through the basics we weren't able to be
able to showcase a real operation but
we're gonna go over the structure of the
code and then talk about basics and then
I'll pass it off to Fabrizio so so so
basically when you get into your tensor
flow that you go to the tensor flow
repository it's a it's structured like a
Python project which means that the
first folder that you need to go into is
actually called tensor flow right so you
go to the main repository you have the
meat readme you'll see a bunch of you
know you see a folder called third party
and you'll see some other things just
for the meat of the actual tensorflow
implementation go into the tensor flow
folder and then from there we're running
so the first the big important folder
that you'll see is core so core has all
the C++ pretty much all the C++
implementations as the kernels it has
the framework itself and it has the
register their so-called registration of
the operations so the inside of
tensorflow slash core you have these
further folders ops is the the
registration of operation signatures the
way that tensorflow works is that it has
a fairly sophisticated and integrated
way of basically saying okay I'm going
to have these operations available to me
and in order for this to run it needs
exactly these these parameters right so
that's registered in score slash ops and
then in the kernels is the actual
implementation of this of this code
right you'll see some files that end
with dot CUDA cc is that right and
though are those are the GPU
implementations and then you'll see
files that are H your header files
see see files but if you want to just
look at all pretty much all the
operations and tensorflow you can go
right into core / kernels if you go into
core / framework you'll actually see the
Enterprise Edition big like the
structured right the the bones holding
everything up and then inside a platform
is our the abstraction that allow them
to you know basically abstract away
different operating systems then if you
go in instead of going into the core
folder instead of tensorflow you go into
python you'll see the python
implementations you'll see wrappers
you'll see test testing you'll see
gradient implementations and you'll see
the the attend the fundamental python
code something that I wanted to write in
if you compile if you installed
tensorflow there's files in the in your
installed version that you won't see in
the repository the so-called gem files
and if you want to really see sort of
what's going on you can look go go into
your either Python or anaconda folder
find your Python library and look at
that those gem files and then finally
there's the coentrão folder there are
other folders in there but the the last
main one is this contributor and that
contains contributed files or parts of
the tensor whole project that aren't
fully adopted yet
yeah and then basically there's so much
documentation inside the code that the
only way that has yet to be written
properly in tutorials that the only way
to get yourself and like into fully to
understand it is to dive right in and
start reading the documentation in the
code
luckily the the Google does a very good
job at documenting their code with
comments so just if you don't understand
something just go in you can go in
deeper right if the easiest way to get
in there is to if you see a function or
a class that you don't understand go up
to the top of your C++ file look for the
include statement that looks like it
goes with it and open up that file
started diving deeper and going down and
deeper and deeper the rabbit down the
rabbit hole right and each one of those
should have really solid explanations
and like yeah it's just gonna be a wild
romp and I had some things like like
just so you know like this is like this
tensorflow
c++ implementation stuff isn't fully
documented it's not documented like
anywhere except in code right so the
only way to know how to use a tensor
when building an operation is to
actually look in the documentation
itself and look at the code itself okay
well I think I'll leave it at that I've
been somewhat files worth checking out
I mean there's there's just a lot of
very cool like utility files very cool
classes that are included in the tensor
flow library that aren't mentioned there
is a how-to on the tensor flow website
called adding an op right how do you add
an operand tensorflow
but for many purposes it's it's not
really complete it goes over the the
high-level view right of what you need
to do but it doesn't talk about what
what actually like the actual C++ API
that you need to to call in order to
make the tensor do the thing you want to
do right so there are a lot of really
useful macros and classes that are
available in the library that Google
that is being used in the code but isn't
made explicitly clear to contributors so
I want you guys to like go in there just
start crawling and diving it's
incredibly well documented so just get
in there learn learn the code and have a
good time with it and again if you want
to contribute they do a fantastic job of
really making you feel comfortable with
your code and making your code better
right and it's your code that's getting
better it's not them it's not them
changing it and then being like thanks I
guess it's just like okay like here
here's the theft here's the thought try
this and then you work on it and you
give it back to them
it's a solid back and forth yes so yeah
so in in CUDA like GPU processing you
have this the idea of a kernel that is
the the code that's going to run on each
of your thread so I believe right more
or less right and in tensor flow the
kernel is simply a C++ implementation of
an operation right it's the code that's
actually running when you call your
Python like function at the top right
cool
no yeah so the word I mean the thing is
the term kernel is used all the time
these days you use it as your kernels
are used for image processing they're
used for
I mean they make sense with
convolutional yeah exactly
convolutional neural networks which
often are used for image processing
right it's in tensorflow
when you hear a kernel in general that
just means an operation implementation
or yeah that's what that means yeah so
basically you can have a kernel for
standard CPU implementation then you can
have a kernel for GPU implementation and
TPU implementation in fact they do
there's this long-standing is it the LS
TM operation that the that this very
very talented contributor is working has
been working on and it's it's supposed
to supposedly with 50 percent faster
than the current LS TM operation so yeah
if you if you know that it's like this
isn't done right you feel free to
re-implement it yourself
similar to spark like what people yeah I
mean the tensorflow people are for
better for worse there's a incredible
amount of attention being paid on this
raw speed right which is important when
you're training like very sophisticated
models and because of that the Google
the Google team working on this is very
interested in having correct fast
implementations happening so if you know
that there's a better way to do this as
a faster implementation you go for it
right because they they will love that
right you know people I love the play
like I know people like sign like Oh
Google is holding out on the good stuff
from us like Google you tease us here's
the years of thing right Google is is
really is interested in having as many
people learning this software and as
fully as humanly possible for all it
from what I understand right and from
what I can tell and from what the
actions of the developers over time the
only parts that aren't in the only parts
that are not in tensorflow right
especially at this point are the things
that are so deep deeply ingrained within
Google's internal infrastructure that it
isn't even relevant to tensorflow
by itself right so the the they work
their butts off to try to get the the
distributed implementation out which is
what we're going to look at next and
they're they're constantly just taking
out in taking internal changes and
pushing them to the the public
repository right they want people to
know this they're interested in having
people who know tensorflow possibly come
in to work with Google and not have to
worry about having to learn tensorflow
from scratch right so Google has like no
reason
to hide the good stuff really there they
would rather have more people use
tensorflow so that they can have more
collaboration and have more good
implementations come in for from the
public Google does a very good job of
trying to trying to like even if the the
initial code is isn't up to up to par
they work with they work very hard to
try to make it good enough and they want
they want the people contributing to
feel like they're valued right and yeah
yeah so for bricio one of the many
things that he's contributed he and he
implemented the ada grad optimization
like he did he did that implementation
for tensorflow
so it's like that was a pretty lengthy
and intensive contribution mojo props
boy my props it's a it's yes yeah the
exact the exact the exact number that
you use as your vector is different for
different you know different reasons
right exactly you can thank you for all
intents and purposes you can look at
they're the same way you would regular
gradient descent or City stochastic
gradient descent or anything like that
in any case thank you so much for
putting up with my incredibly heat long
a presentation thank you so much for
sticking
you